a través de la ventana de su casa
anatoly vio llegar a los rusos
era un minibús blanco con una letra Z me
acerqué a la puerta para mirar por la
mirilla
vinieron y tocaron el timbre abre la
puerta
anatoly fue detenido y torturado durante
24 días
tienen una especie de anillos y cables
los atan y los retuercen
si giran rápidamente la persona puede
caer con una potencia media a uno se
pone en cuclillas si lo hacen lentamente
es soportable pero dan convulsiones
en cada interrogatorio
atan estos cables y encima lo golpean a
uno
a excepción de mi cabeza todo mi cuerpo
estaba azul
desde el cuello hasta las rodillas una
vez su estructuradores le obligaron a
saltar durante una hora y media si no
saltaba me enviaban fuertes descargas si
me ponía en cuclillas me pegaban con
palos
si saltaba enviaba en choques eléctricos
débiles y no me golpeaban lo entienden
los seres humanos no se comportan así
anatoly fue liberado a principios de
septiembre justo antes de que las
fuerzas ucranianas entrarán en
palaclilla si los rusos se hubieran
quedado cree que habría sido peor
habrían matado a muchas personas y
dejado iniciadas a otras
habría sido el terror pero el terror
estalinista
en la mira de las fuerzas rusas Los
Patriotas ucranianos como anatoli
antiguo miembro del Consejo local ahora
ha vuelto a trabajar en el mercado una
aparente regreso a la vida normal
los que estaban en la cámara de tortura
conmigo Ahora son como mi familia
no nos vemos porque todo el mundo está
ocupado Pero a veces vienen a verme aquí
en el mercado de los clientes vuelven a
agruparse en los pasillos
y los trabajadores están ocupados donde
las bombas han causado destrucciones
se acerca el invierno y tenemos que
movernos rápido
Esto no es nada Comparado con las vidas
esto se puede arreglar
pero no las vidas humanas
estaban torturando a la gente en la
estación de policía se podían oír los
gritos
la comisaría de policía donde los rusos
habían instalado una cámara de tortura
reanudó sus funciones este hombre que
también se llama anatoly vino a
solicitar un nuevo pasaporte
la razón por la quenatoly tiene que
renovar su pasaporte es porque los rusos
Se lo quitaron cuando lo retuvieron aquí
durante 100 días no se siente bien estar
de vuelta aquí fui a ver los agujeros de
bala y las marcas de sangre en las
paredes pero lo limpiaron no queda nada
me interrogaron
me golpearon me electrocutaron querían
que hiciera vídeos
alabando a Putin y a su ejército de
reclutas y que los mostrara en mi canal
de YouTube
me negué
por eso me retuvieron tanto tiempo
una vez incluso me llevaron y me dijeron
que me iban a fusilar
Pero se acabó
estoy vivo gracias a Dios
cuando anatoly y su esposa se marchan
esa transeúnte se detiene para contarnos
que su hijo un juez también fue
torturado en esta comisaría
hombres con pasamontañas negros se lo
llevaron
se negó y quedó en libertad pero fue
detenido de nuevo en dos ocasiones
también amenazan con ejecutarlo por
perseguir a los separatistas prorrusos
Durante un mes y medio hasta que regresó
el ejército ucraniano esperábamos que
nos dispararan y arrestaran en cualquier
momento incluso sé quién es la
desgraciada Que lo denunció diciendo que
tenía fichas de los separatistas
ella era la única que lo sabía Y esa
zorra pasea tranquilamente por
balaclilla
a caterina le gustaría que se
persiguieran los informantes y
colaboradores pero el juzgado donde
trabaja su hijo no volverá a funcionar
pronto
saquearon todo
el equipo el computador la impresora el
dictáfono
preguntamos a Bolo por los detalles de
las detenciones de las que nos habló su
madre
en casa me obligaron a sentarme junto al
radiador
me apuntaron con un arma a la pierna
amenazaron con romperme las piernas las
rodillas
luego me llevaron a la plaza y me
dispararon por encima de la cabeza con
una pistola macaro
luego me retuvieron durante otra hora en
la comisaría
Y así sucesivamente
historias como esta y muchas otras se
pueden escuchar en todas las localidades
recuperadas de los rusos por el ejército
ucraniano